Speaker 1: Failed. Former President Donald Trump
had a complete and total meltdown over the MAGA
disaster in the 2022 midterms. Tantrum
ing like a child over the last 24 hours,
Trump has gone cuckoo. And as it increasingly
became clear there will be no red wave,
there might be a ripple. We're still waiting,
but there's not going to be a wave. As it
becomes clear that Trump's likely forthcoming
presidential run announcement next Tuesday at
Mar a Lago may not be met with open arms by
Republicans. We'll get to that a little bit later.
Donald Trump pulling out all the stops, stops and
making a complete and total fool out of himself.
Here is a real quote from Trump about last night's
results on News Nation. If Republicans win,
he should get all the credit. If Republicans
lose, he should get no blame at all. That's not
a joke. That's actually what Trump said.
Speaker 4: You've endorsed more than 330
candidates this election cycle. Tonight,
win or lose the results for Republicans.
How much of that will be because of Donald Trump?
Speaker 2: Well, I think if they win,
I should get all the credit. And if they
lose, I should not be blamed at all.
Okay. But it'll probably be just the opposite.
Speaker 1: He he's saying it with a straight face,
guys. He's not joking. It's just like with COVID,
where he said, I don't take any responsibility.
He's not joking.
Speaker 2: When they win, I
think they're going to do very well. I'll probably
be given very little credit, even though in many
cases I tell people to run and they ran and they
turned out to be very good candidates. You know,
they've turned out to be very good candidates. But
usually what would happen is when they do well,
they won't be given any credit. And if they do
badly, they will blame everything on me. So I'm
prepared for anything. But we'll defend ourselves.
Speaker 1: What a victim. What a victim. Now,
he said it again with a completely straight
face as Arizona started looking shaky and
people like Kari Lake and Blake Masters and
Charlie Kirk started panicking and saying,
we've we've got to start claiming that there is
fraud here. Donald Trump took to truth social
and delivered a very, very strange message. Trump
looking disheveled and confused and gaunt to some
degree, and again suggesting that they there
is some conspiracy to prevent them from voting
in Arizona. There was no such conspiracy.
Here's Trump delivering a panicked message.
Speaker 2: To the great
people of Arizona, Maricopa
County in particular. Don't leave your line.
Stay where you are. They say that the machines
are working. They say that they're running out of
paper in different locations throughout different
states. There's a lot of bad things going on. Stay
on line. Do not leave. I know you don't want to be
there as long as they're going to try and force
you. They want to delay you out of voting, right?
Speaker 1: They want to
delay you. Why? I don't know.
Speaker 2: And you cannot let them delay
you out of voting. So to the people of
Arizona in particular, because that's the one
that's come up right now. Stay on line. Don't
leave. Already a lot of people have left
and it's very, very unfair what's going
on. Maricopa County, don't leave. Stay there.
Speaker 1: All right. Again, we already sorted out
the Arizona stuff at the top of the show. There
was really no big deal going on there. At issue
with the tabulator, they dealt with it. No
evidence that anybody's votes were suppressed
in any way. And then Donald Trump posting about
his endorsement record, Remember what matters is
his own endorsement record to him. Impossible to
pretend they all won. Trump posting that he was
174 and nine a great evening and the fake news
media. Together with their partner in crime,
the Democrats are doing everything possible
to play it down. Amazing job by some really
fantastic candidates. And remember, Trump
mostly is endorsing incumbents and people who
are obviously going to win but do not be confused.
The Republican Party is really considering whether
it's time to bail on Trump because a lot of
his big endorsements lost mastriano that was
a critical race. Lost Oz, lost Tudor, Dixon,
lost Carrie Lake and Blake Masters may lose. We
don't yet know. It's a long list. Lee Zeldin lost.
This was not a particularly good night for Trump.
When you look at endorsements for the critical
races that really matter, not a particularly
good night. Trump knows it. Republicans know
it. We'll get to that a little bit later.